I'm not I don't know anyone who's gonna
be in the car with me I have no idea who
these people I like strangers so we're
going to Pismo Beach to see elephants
you know like seasoned seal that'd be
kind of cool
got my Australian accent ready to go oh
okay it's a lot of build up Sardar
painting your voice can be like don't
ever crack your knees or elbows I made
it right now I've never taken too
[Music]
zombie apocalypse no tickets but we
really need this even field I'm just
hoping they're like what is little bit
well then we call them you do your best
what is an elephant close the Sun is not
set
[Music]
I'm so glad that we made it the Sun is
literally setting right now and we did
see the seals beeping they're all
strangers like we were I think I met
three new friends I think I probably
talk too much but I've been hearing that
since like kindergarten it would be nice
to stay a little longer and see what's
around on taking this and enjoyed this
moment right now
everyone was so open to talking and
friendly conversation we had a really
good time love to laugh
we got to know each other
well you're saying you tired yeah I'm
tired yeah Gabriel
[Music]